more than 70 thousand people have
benefited from a rental assistance
program in the county that money though
it is running out there is a deadline
quickly approaching Sunday evening 8
news now investigator Vanessa Murphy
explains from a help center which many
tenants are turning to
more than 500 people came here for help
on Wednesday usually they help about 300
people a day but this increase is
expected to continue as evictions ramp
up as a dad you just want to fix it
foreign
Derek Floyd says he's a single father of
two facing evictions
it's kind of hard to find a job with no
child care and that's been the biggest
struggle with me he tells us he last
paid rent in November received an
eviction notice last year and then filed
an application with the cares housing
assistance program also known as chap on
Sunday night that current program ends
the online application shuts down before
midnight we understand that a lot of
people are currently depending on the
old version of chap a lot of people have
applied a lot of people have exhausted
their chap chap eligibility at this
point so are unable to apply so we do
anticipate more people coming in with
eviction notices Ryan McConnell is an
attorney with the legal aid center of
Southern Nevada which helps tenants here
if you get an eviction notice you need
to file an answer or you could be locked
out within a matter of a couple weeks he
says Nevada is unique because of its
seven-day summary eviction process it's
up to the tenant to file the first
document in a court case after they've
received the eviction notice this causes
an expedited process for evictions Floyd
says while he waits for an answer about
chap he's here to follow his case and
keep a roof over his boy's heads it's
real scary but everybody's telling me
just to sit tight and we don't know
what's going to happen
in case you need to visit the civil law
self-help center it's located here in
the Regional Justice Center the
information desk is right here once you
get through security the office is right
to the left reporting in downtown Las
Vegas Vanessa Murphy 8 News Now